[Music]
hey you guys yeah i am what are you
talking about you do a downbeat
sometimes we do this upbeat thank you
for coming to the show
all right
so today is
fourth of july independence day
yeah i'm probably gonna watch the
fireworks from my back window
yeah i'm not i'm not going outside it's
like 90 degrees and there's
[ __ ] that [ __ ] they launch a whole bunch
of fireworks well they've been doing
them all weekend like we like we went to
the club last night and when we were on
the way there like on the toll roads
there were fireworks all over the place
all over the [ __ ] city they're
already getting ready to do fireworks
everywhere so you know
they're going crazy with fireworks
action
yeah they must be like saving them up
you know what i mean right but uh yeah
okay so we're talking about
amityville [ __ ] two amyville ii the
possession the possession the possession
which was uh kind of like amityville and
the exorcist combined
with the hot chick from [ __ ] last
american version
her job was just to show up be pretty
and take her clothes off that's what she
did mostly in movies when you saw it
back when i was a teenager you saw her
you were going to see some titties
unless it was better off dead yeah i
don't think she should have said that
yeah also she i think she was in bill
and ted's excellent adventure was she
but i don't know if she got naked in
that but i think she was in terror
vision also you remember that movie i
think it was a terrible movie it was
terrible any about anything about it
other than it was terrible maybe maybe
she was a b-movie queen mostly yeah that
girl she was yeah what's her name do you
have it do you have a diane franklin
dianne franklin yeah yeah yeah she's
cute as [ __ ] yeah
i mean you know what the hell's
happening okay nothing's happening no
something i saw that [ __ ] freak out
danny rowling says this film in my
opinion is the best haunted house film
uh next to poltergeist original do you
know that there are a not insignificant
portion of uh horror fans on the
internet who like this one better than
the original amityville horror
uh roger ebert did as well now he wasn't
a big fan of the first sandyville horror
and he wasn't a huge fan of this one
either but he thought this one was
better
yeah maybe i would think so maybe i
would say technically probably better
better quality but the first one does
have a certain amount of charm to it
that's true it's kind of like a kind of
like a low budget version of an episode
of the haunting when you see it now it
did kind of scare you you know back in
those days but you know your threshold
was lower back then
this one i kind of feel like uh because
it was an italian director
so uh they just leaned into the sleaze
yeah and um you know what i mean which
we'll get into in a bit and actually it
was much worse uh but they had to cut a
lot of it okay um because italy yeah
damiano damiani was yeah he was yeah he
did a [ __ ] down of movies but not that
many like then you had to get asses into
seats though they knew how to get
[ __ ] boys to come see the damn movie
yeah you know
which is sleazy [ __ ]
yeah this one's very sleazy and like i
said it's it's very kind of um it's over
the top like the haunting [ __ ] because i
kind of feel like amityville horror and
this isn't to its detriment the original
one i kind of feel like it was more
restrained more subtle like it went
batshit crazy like toward the end like
with the walls bleeding and all that
stuff but
this one i mean within like the first
five or ten minutes there's like crazy
[ __ ] happening you know what i mean like
crazy paranormal [ __ ] but
i don't know there's something about
this i saw this when i was younger and
then i think i saw it again like
probably five or ten years ago and
there's just something that's kind of i
guess it's the sleaze factor
there's i don't know there's something
like really kind of like
[ __ ] up but also kind of like
appealing about it
yeah another thing about it is that it
kind of in general parts of it
do kind of conform to the defeo case at
least superficially and then they've
they've included a lot of legend about
that case and a bunch of fantasy about
that case and the theories from that
case are all in this it's kind of like
an homage to the veil case
well they're supposed to be the defeo
family they just had to like change the
names and it's not like yeah for those
who don't know who that is that was the
dude that killed his family in that
amityville horror house before the
letters moved in yeah so that did happen
like it did happen the weird thing about
this though is that it's a it's
it's sort of like a prequel they never
come out and say like what year it is or
even though it's clearly set in 1982
like when the movie came out and the
original movie was obviously the 70s
yeah so making a period piece yeah so
they were just kind of like we're not
going to bother so it's just kind of
like a loose prequel
danny rowling brought up tommy lee
wallace who wrote the screenplay and i
wanted to bring him up too because tommy
lee wallace you might be interested to
know was the same guy who directed
halloween three season of the witch
he also directed fright night two which
isn't too bad uh and the stephen king's
it from 1990. okay yeah he was like a
big um he did [ __ ] with like john
carpenter all the time he was actually
one of the editors on the original
halloween and on the fog
and i think he got like he was art
director on darkstar you know what i
mean yeah so yeah he worked with john
carpenter all the time so he was the one
that wrote the screenplay like i said
the director was like an italian dude
now what ended up happening with this
now we've talked about the lutz family
before and how we think that they're
they were probably full of crap and they
were just trying to like make money
off because like i said ronnie defeo did
actually like shoot his entire family in
the house that did happen um but then
like all the haunting stuff
i think was [ __ ] and they were just
trying to make money so they did the
book with jay anson now what i wasn't
aware of is that there was a second book
and it was called amityville horror part
two and it wasn't written by jay anson
it was written by another guy named john
jones
and i guess the lutz's
wanted that to be made into a movie i
don't know what that book is about like
i guess it was like their story
continued or whatever
but
when they were thinking about because
the original andyville horror was so
successful and they're like okay well
we're going to make another one and dino
de laurentiis had the production like
had you know was gonna do it
but he was like no i want to base the
second one on
hans holzer's book now hans holter is a
parapsychologist right and he wrote a
book called murder in amityville which
was kind of more
going along like i said the possession
angle cause you know when ronnie defeo
got arrested one of his story well one
of his many stories
one of his stories was that uh he was
possessed by a devil or he had or he
heard voices that like
yeah that like kill a whole family so i
guess like hans holtzer as a
parapsychologist wrote a book
coming at it from that angle like the
angle that the house was actually
haunted and so they decided they were
going to make a movie out of that george
lutz was pissed he sued
dino de laurentiis but he lost
um i think the only thing that they did
after that was they would put like
little stickers like on the posters for
this movie
that you know this movie doesn't have
anything to do with the lutzes but like
i said this is supposed to be a prequel
but it's set after it's confusing but
it's obviously supposed to be the defeo
family but they all have their names
changed so it's kind of like for legal
reasons for legal reasons yeah um if you
know the case well the ambivalent horror
case you know what they're talking about
and you know
yeah you know who they're talking about
and it does really kind of like like the
sun the oldest son that ends up like
shooting everybody you know in real life
he was named ronnie right ronald defeo
um in the movie he's sunny i think
they're the montelli's right
i think that yeah it's like the montelli
family
yeah and he's not portrayed as how he
really was in real life he's kind of
portrayed as a nice guy who fell to this
demonic force in reality [ __ ] ronnie
defeo was
he was a junkie he was kind of a scumbag
he was a scumbag
lived with his parents he spent a lot of
time in the bars getting high and doing
two-bit drug deals and getting in
trouble that's that's who he really was
he was just falling into damn drug abuse
drug addiction for some reason he killed
his family one night but it was an
abusive family's dad beat everybody up
which they do portray in this movie yeah
and actually the guy bert young that
plays the dad who's you know probably
best and he's been into [ __ ] ton stuff
but he's best known as paulie from rock
from the rocky movies yeah and um he
usually plays a good guy though i feel
like but wow in this one
uh he just slaps everybody around slaps
his wife around slaps his kids around
there's actually a deleted scene from
this
where he
butt rapes his wife
because she's not giving it up okay yeah
all right uh also because because uh
blairdo dude says i imagine this movie
is a fave with incest files yeah that's
what i was gonna say now this version
that's on because we watched on uh
i think we watched on hbo max
and there is
incest between sonny the older uh the
older son and the daughter
like they're kind of close in age i feel
like
the one played by the frankly i guess
they were related weren't they yeah okay
well yeah cause i think in real life
um they were related in real life yeah
they were i think it was all one i
thought it was a step family but i'm
confusing them with the lutz is because
the lutz's that was like
those were step kids like those weren't
his actual kids but this was an actual
family now nobody knows like i said this
is
i think that was another story that
ronnie defeo came up with
that him and his sister
were having an insect incestuous
relationship and she like helped him
yeah it helped him do the murders but i
don't know no there's no evidence no
there's no evidence of that and um and
he killed her too so i don't really know
like why that was another one of the
stories the most mysterious thing of in
the real case of why
uh
uh he you know
the most
the most mysterious things about the
original case is
how the hell
why the hell were they all killed in bed
you know well that's what everybody is
like because they're like you think that
you would hear like somebody would have
woken up but there were other cases
where they were all shot in bed even
though they were awake and it's because
a lot of times little kids will hide
underneath the covers in the bed like
that's going to save them yeah
and
i think what it is he blasted the
parents first
and then
she was probably in bed
he goes into her room and [ __ ] she's
like what was that all about he said he
says i killed my parents and she
probably he probably leveled the gun at
her and she put her head down and he
shot her and
shot her while she was on the bed like
that and then the little kids were
cowering in bed and he
they so i think it's just it was
surprised
and their reactions were to just freeze
like deer in the headlights
yeah that doesn't seem that crazy to me
because one they were kids yeah two it's
your brother right like and you just
probably think he's like [ __ ] around
or you're not sure what's happening yeah
it's like you don't really expect like
your older brother to like go around
shooting everybody so it would be like
shocking and he probably did it pretty
quickly that's what i'm thinking yeah a
few seconds there's a lever action
marlin rifle it was a 444 marlin
um which is live loud hunting hunting
rifle
i'll ever actually run hunting car being
really like a real fat long 44 magnum
bullet
but nobody they said well nobody heard
the shooting they thought that was
paranormal in the original case but no
you can touch off a pretty powerful
round inside a house which i used to do
it every now and then with a proper
snail trap trap the bullet because when
i was hand loading and stuff i test out
a load but you know that was but now the
neighbors won't hear it because uh the
the walls kind of absorb it all
and
if it was in the middle of the night
everybody'd be asleep it wouldn't be
enough to wake them up
i mean even if it did like you might
think whoa was that noise or you thought
you think you were dreaming it or
something yeah i don't think it would
get you out of a sleep if it was the
houses next door it's not that loud you
know
the house would contain the
sonic blast you know the sonic boom
although i'm not even sure if 444 mullin
is
ultrasonic it might be subsonic i'd have
to go look at it depends on what kind of
ammunition he used you know this is a
big heavy slow bullet
although i guess it's not moving so
moving slow for a rifle not a pistol but
it's just
22 25 even 9 millimeter you can shoot
those in the house all day long as long
as you have a safe way of trapping the
bullet catching it
neighbors should never know
danny rowling says andrew prine aka the
sheriff from the town that treaded
sundown plays the priest's gay boyfriend
in this yeah see okay i recognized him i
had forgotten that he was in town that
dreaded sundown i recognized him from
i want to say it was grisly but i could
be wrong it was some 70s eco horror like
or animal attacks movie that i saw of
like very recently so i was like maybe
it was grizzly because i watched that on
like riff tracks not too long ago he was
like i mean he's only in it and it's
funny because they don't specifically
say that he's like the priest gay
boyfriend but i kind of were like hey
that was kind of like interesting that
he kind of i mean they don't say that in
the movie but that's kind of what i
thought too because he's like going on
the camping trip and
you know the um the daughter like
patricia diane franklin's character
she's like trying to call the priest
because she's like hey i think my
brother's gonna kill us all and he's
just like i'm going on a camping trip
i'm not gonna answer that [ __ ] right now
and then they all get killed like that
night and then he feels really bad about
it and then her ghost or the haunted
house or something like that like calls
him
like it with her voice which actually i
thought was a really creepy scene i
really liked that like when the phone
rang and he picked it up and it was her
like after she was already dead because
that's the thing it's like
i had forgotten when i watched this
movie but i don't know why i would have
forgotten it because this is kind of
what happened in real life but
i thought that most of the movie was
like leading up to
the multiple murder but it's not like he
basically like shoots the whole family
what like halfway through
i think it was about halfway through the
movie and then like the rest of it is
the priest like coming to terms with the
fact that sonny is possessed and like
trying to get the demon out it becomes
the exorcist pretty much i mean it
really does well they they
it's both horror movies they both
exorcists made a lot of money and so did
dannyville horror so the part two was
going to have ebony vahreh and the
exorcist combined
hey why not i mean might as well and
it's an italian director that'd be
that'd be the guy to get
yeah and italian oh [ __ ] it we're gonna
put we're gonna put the exorcist in this
movie okay yeah yeah we'll do that well
and it's justifiable because it was kind
of based on the book and ronnie defeo
did say like so voices tell me so so he
left the door open and there was a whole
thing about ambivale oh the house is
haunted and blah blah so and lutz said
he was possessed and all that other kind
of crap too so it's not like they were
just pulling it right out of their butt
they just you know ronnie left the door
open the director walked right through
it
we're gonna go that way
and uh made a decent movie
pretty good i actually i had forgotten
like kind of how good this was and
honestly like there's a lot of really
good actors like i said like um
the you know the guy that plays polly
from rocky burt young he's in it and
then the woman that plays the mom
dolores
i was like [ __ ] man i just saw her in
something the other day she's been in a
ton of stuff too her name is um reutanya
alda she was in
mommy dearest i was like that's right
because we just watched mommy dearest
like not too long ago she played like
the housekeeper or like her like uh
what's her name like assistant or
whatever she was in rocky too also and
she was in the deer hunter
like but yeah she's been in a ton of
[ __ ] so
i don't know like i really like i said i
kind of like
i mean you could argue that this is kind
of like exploitative because it's based
on like a real case but
i don't know i kind of feel like they do
that a lot with horror movies they did
like change everybody's names it is very
similar to the actual case
but
some of the stuff has been changed
around but
but they did seem to have
because the character that bert young
plays like the dad
that's pretty much what they said about
the defeo dad too that he just like
slapped everybody around and he was like
a real [ __ ]
and
they show that in this movie too i mean
in this movie he's a dick he's a oh man
he's a dick and a half i mean he's just
like not only does he slap his whole
entire family around
but
he also like when the priest comes
because like supernatural [ __ ] starts
happening like almost immediately like i
think like
like the night or the next day when
they're moving to the house like you
know [ __ ] starts going crazy and they're
like oh ghosts or whatever and then she
goes to the priest
and gets him to come bless the house and
when he turns up at the house like the
dad is basically just like actually a
total douche tank
in defense in in defense of the defeos
or daddy defeo what was his name i don't
remember what his real name was yeah
what was it well i think he was ronald
defeo senior because i thought like the
kid was a junior in defense of him some
people have said that he he
that you might think that he was abusive
by today's standards but for the
standards of the 70s he was just kind of
a little bit outside the norm for an
italian authoritarian type
husband
that was kind of common in that area
just you know
dude trying to put his foot down and
running the family you know just
kind of old school
um
you know if some if a kid got out of
line he'd smack a kid but they did that
you know so i'm not sure
because some people have said that
ronnie defeo during his trial
tried to make him seem more abusive than
he was to try to get leniency
for you know going crazy but i don't
know that yeah i mean that's the thing
it's like there's it's just kind of his
word it's yeah
and
other people who knew him said yeah he
was kind of a tough he was a tough
italian
father figure who didn't take any [ __ ]
but they didn't know of him as being
like abusive like you know beating the
wives or anything like that
although sometimes
that was something they didn't really
talk about like back then so if it was
going on behind closed doors i wouldn't
know and the whole family's dead yeah so
it's not like you have anybody else's
word for all we know dude might have you
know [ __ ] his son was a [ __ ]
multiple murderer for all we know you
know what i mean he made it yeah so it's
kind of like yeah you know i i've just
been a hard ass like my stepdad
you know yeah something like that
lionex warrior says uh the mafia
connections are interesting wasn't like
when he tried to blame it on him yeah i
thought that was another story trying to
make a little bob hit like a mob head at
first yeah like
mob would never do anything like that
yeah that really was family-oriented
that really doesn't seem like a mob i
mean nice try but uh but way out of
character for the mob yeah definitely
they didn't go after families and women
and children and [ __ ]
not unless they were guilty
of something yeah but
no
i don't think they ever really got a
motive for why he did it
because he was a loon a lunatic
i mean you know probably was getting in
trouble he probably got in trouble and
they punished him
then he said [ __ ] it i'm killing him and
killed the dad and realized he had to
kill everybody he was probably gonna
kill himself been chickened out that's
probably what it was i kind of suspect
it was probably just something like that
i think he was mostly like just
targeting his dad for whatever reason um
and then was just kind of like oh well
if i kill everybody i'm gonna kill
everybody i can just say yeah yeah and
like you said he might have gonna kill
himself as well because they i don't
know like in this movie i don't know
what it was like in real life like i
said i didn't know them but
uh in this movie this is uh because when
we were watching it i said wow this
family puts the fun and dysfunctional
doesn't it holy crap it's just like
from the second they like move in it's
just like oh it's gonna be so fun in
this house and that it's just like this
you know kind of
cauldron of turmoil it's like
in reality ronnie defeo was the
amityville horror he was the animal
[ __ ] he was the demon that's a that's
that's what it was yeah and it was like
it was no demons it was no ghost made
him do it nothing like that he was just
a [ __ ] loon and decided he was heroin
heroin and alcohol and [ __ ] not get
in his way and being a semi loser and
probably depressed and [ __ ]
couldn't take it anymore [ __ ]
for all we know his dad took maybe gave
him a timeline you're out of this house
next week type of [ __ ] and [ __ ] you
know yeah it had to be some kind of like
catalyst yeah
that he couldn't survive on his own so
yeah and he was just kind of like oh i'm
not gonna be able to yeah i i can see
that totally he could not he couldn't
hold a job and then the fact that he had
to come up with
you know oh it was first it was the
mafia hit then oh voices told me to and
then oh i was sister [ __ ] probably
he helps me and blah blah blah something
like they were going to kick him out
because he was a freeloader he couldn't
keep couldn't keep a job and just
[ __ ] he couldn't clean himself up so
he gave him time you better get the [ __ ]
here you're out of here on such and such
a date and that date started he got high
and drunk and that date was approaching
and he it was murder suicide he's going
to kill the whole family and and himself
type of deal probably something like
that yeah and then chickened out when it
came his turn but he's like no i don't
think i want to do that
this he was a weedy little dude and he
was a slime ball you know you know he
wasn't in you know just
not a tough guy he probably thought he
was a tough guy but he was just a weedy
little slime ball
junkie
probably thought he was a real tough guy
and uh broke down in the moment of
weakness and just killed everybody and
then couldn't [ __ ] kill himself
you know yeah but you definitely had
that pathological liar speech pattern
and when you see interviews with him
he's a pathological liar is he still
alive
well i don't know but they would
interview him from prison all the time
and it's just you you're
that funny speech pattern that
pathological liars have
yeah i mean like i said that all the
stories he came up with
i don't know like we did a show about
the amityville horror like a long time
ago yeah but
uh lawyers and [ __ ] movie people and
[ __ ] got involved with this story and he
uh tried to [ __ ] uh go to court and
say he was possessed and he was trying
to get leniency somehow
but there's no way he's going to beat
that many life sentences
gilded age phoenix said he died in 2021
oh okay so recently okay
but yeah that's a they did actually
shoot this movie in at the same house at
least the exteriors not sure about the
interiors but uh yeah it's the same uh
same house they shot at but um i kind of
wanted to do the third one too but
because i think that's also on hbo max i
don't remember what happened in that one
i thought that one was also kind of
based on the defeo family was based on
like a different book i didn't think
that it was like a continuation of this
one
aren't there like how many [ __ ]
amityville movies are there now i don't
know
i think at least five
see i thought that there was more like i
thought it was like up into the double
digits was it okay but i could be wrong
now we did see
uh probably like last year the year
before we went to rifftrax live and they
did amityville
four
i think a medieval four i think it's
called it's about time
and
see i didn't even realize too i knew
about the first amityville horror book
and then when i was researching this
movie i was like oh there was an
annieville ii and then there was one
that about the defeats but the
supernatural angle and there was like
different ones but there was also
this series i think i don't know if it's
one book or if it's like a series but
it's called like amp like amityville
like the evil escapes or something and
it's like people that had to the [ __ ]
that doesn't even take place in the
house like people that went to the house
for whatever reason and then later
they're like ooh i had supernatural [ __ ]
like happening
on like at my house like you know a
million miles away which maybe is where
they got the idea for amityville four
because in that one that doesn't even
take place at the original house that
take place out of [ __ ] california
somewhere or something like that and it
has to do with like some [ __ ]
lamp or some [ __ ] what's the lamp
yeah it was like a haunted lamp in
california amityville the haunted lamp
that's what it should have been called
it was terrible um but yeah so the layup
like this old lady like buys it from a
garage sale and then like takes it back
to her house and
i think kelly yeah somewhere out in your
house or something or she buys it for
her sister or some [ __ ] and then like
the
the
the the layup makes her house like
possessed it had nothing to do with it
it's just they just slapped that label
on the phone that's what i suspected
like when i saw that one i was just kind
of like this wasn't even an amityville
to start with they just wrote this
little framework at the beginning so
they can put that we're going to make
this movie and we're going to somehow
connect it with amityville oh okay well
we'll say the lamp came from avenueville
yeah that's what it is yeah that's the
ticket
they just probably bought the license
for it for for for ambivale so that
you remember the movie because they
bought that license if they didn't buy
that license you would have forgotten
about that movie because it sucked yeah
because it would have just been called
the haunted lamp haunted land
i feel like they do that a lot
especially in horror yeah you know if
they get like a script they're like oh
hey this is kind of a neat story but
you're a nobody and it's like not an ip
that anybody recognizes so let's kind of
finagle a few details and then we'll
call it final destination 13 or whatever
like part of like a success we're gonna
make this part of the omen series yeah
oh okay why not do that yeah well just
like she wanted it yeah i mean i can see
why they do that like i'm sure it makes
more money but makes money
but yeah so uh
let me say i saw something here
uh
check out ryan's oh defeo's last
interview before he died like somebody's
saying about that and then uh what do
you say just get to the point what did
you say oh i don't see that okay as well
he's saying to check it out but there's
got to be a reason danny rowling's
[ __ ] just lied every time yeah i
would i wouldn't believe anything would
he say what he says said the amityville
doll house was the weakest of the series
but had scary-looking demons in it which
one is that one i don't remember that
one
yeah i have to like because like i don't
even i don't even remember how many of
there are there are once the [ __ ] starts
going on for too long you know you
shouldn't really see it uh with the
exception of maybe friday the 13th
because you know that's going to be a
[ __ ] show and and that they can keep
that [ __ ] show rolling and at least you
were laughing through a lot of it
well at least they knew what they were
doing they're like jason's in space yeah
yeah
yeah
you're like okay put it on
sorry that yeah you know for some reason
when i when i said that do you remember
last night we were coming home from the
club and we don't go to that club like
that often so we still have to put the
gps on the phone and so i put the gps on
and we're leaving the
parking lot and it's like in this
industrial park so you kind of have to
think and so we're going around the
corner and she says like in 800 feet
like turn left bro
whatever and tom's like she doesn't know
what she's doing i was like that [ __ ]
is talking to you from space yeah yeah
yeah
and i went yeah that's right
she just slapped his ass off i was like
what it's true she's in space she can
see you from up there yeah she knows
where she's going the um
now
i must say that the the exorcist series
some of them were pretty good
x's two wasn't that good
three and four i think and what was it
five they weren't that bad they were
pretty exorcist three was actually quite
it was actually really good that was the
exorcist two was awful which is the one
that had george c scott in it that was
part three three yeah yeah that was a
good one and then four was the one where
it had all the special effects right
were they the one with all the special
effects demons are fighting out on the
dam
the dean they're fighting pazuzu
in the mountains yeah i can't remember
because didn't we review like a couple
of those like yeah and there's like two
different versions and there's two
different versions of essentially the
same movie yeah yeah yeah we talked
about that yeah mike barrett said i
always liked the second amityville more
than the first yeah you're not actually
not the only one um there's actually a
pretty significant uh portion of people
that actually think that
the second amityville is better and i
can see that like i said um because it's
an italian director it has like a
slightly different
angle to it and you know it leans into
the sleeves and it leans into
you know it amps up like the paranormal
[ __ ] it's a good movie it's actually
like pretty decent it was like more
decent than i remember it's a good
horror movie yeah but it doesn't have
for me
i guess you could say kind of like the
gravitas as the as of the first one
because i was a kid when the first one
came out and saw it when it was pretty
new i don't know if i saw it in the
theater or not though i may have
i think maybe kimmy took me to see that
i'm not sure
but that's my babysitter
but but what year did that come out 79
yeah so i might have yeah i might have
still maybe had a babysitter at that
time could have been about ten or eleven
right yeah
yeah you've been ten ten ten
so i think she took me to see that one
but uh
there was what made it scary is that
there was a plausibility to it you were
told that this was based on something
that actually did happen not everybody
saw it but evidently it did happen
and out in california at the time when i
saw
all the little teenagers and [ __ ] and
kimmy and her friends and [ __ ] you know
they all believed that that was real it
was a true story so i had been hyped
by hearing these little teenage girls
going oh we're going to see that you
know i think they took me to see it but
i heard them talking about that one they
also talked about the exorcist like that
that actually happened
reality was very warped in the 70s
especially amongst real young people
they had a hard time differentiating
between
what was real and what wasn't
i mean you could say that the exorcist
is very loosely based on something right
well i would say that on not really a
true story but it's a claim to be then
they also
they also there was like a couple of
other cases they were constantly talking
about in the 70s when i was a kid
um
civil they would talk about that
they would talk about audrey rose
or aubrey rose
audrey rose yeah as if that was real
that was all well that was purported to
be real because i read the book as well
trying to think of another one that they
said was real they thought carrie might
have been real
okay that's absolutely nov
[Laughter]
or they suspected that it was real i
mean it didn't even make any claims i
mean stephen king wrote it that was like
his first novel yeah but you know
13 14 year old girls thought that was
real that oh yeah that happens you know
that kind of [ __ ] you know
it's actually this and that but they
didn't use her name that kind of stuff
but they actually thought that gene
simmons could just spit fire
all right without any preparation that
he could be standing there and spit fire
and that uh his tongue was a foot long
and forked they believed that
they believed that
it's true they believed that it was a
weird time
70s was a hell of a drug okay [ __ ]
they believed in the 70s teenage girls
believed that
that um
gene simmons tongues was forked that he
had slit it and that hadn't happened
that he didn't do that that people did
that later crazy people yeah yeah i've
seen some people that had that done yeah
but they thought and that he had
something cut so he could make it come
out a foot long but he didn't do that
all the time just weird [ __ ]
i'd heard i had heard they believed all
kinds of stuff as well i don't think i
ever believed it but i didn't really
think about it all that much because i
wasn't in the kiss
i told the story i i got to dig up that
picture of [ __ ] kimmy and so i can
put it on my tablet so i can show her to
show her to the audience she looked like
princess leia exactly like and
my mother would give me to her and i was
like the [ __ ] she was like the nanny
in a way but she only lived two houses
down
you know
and uh that's my girlfriend she's
dragging baby time dragging me back but
she dropped the pookie
[Laughter]
back when tom was the boo back when i
was a pookie i
get invited to all the slumber parties
and [ __ ]
i'm like six five six and [ __ ]
teenage girls hugging on me in the chat
[ __ ] they're getting high and
listening to the [ __ ] led zepplin red
baby sounds baby god yeah i was like the
best guy
it was a good time it was a good time
but yeah so
so yeah this movie they kind of like
apparently it's kind of [ __ ] up i mean
but it was apparently like a lot worse
as i said there and i don't know if
these scenes still exist anywhere like i
don't think there's a director's cut or
nothing but apparently the the original
one had like i said had the butt raping
scene yeah where the dad like butt rapes
the mom
and so that was in there and also
because if you watch the movie now like
with the brother and sister when they
start getting it on that whole scene is
like
creepy
like where he's and well i think the
creepiest thing is that she just like
goes along with it he's like you're the
most beautiful girl in the whole world
and he's like just take your nightgown
off and she's like
no oh well okay and i'm just like dude
that's like your brother that's so weird
and then he's like i'm pretending that
i'm like this famous photographer and
like she's like doing that and then like
they start making out and i'm just kind
of like okay so that's how it is in
their family
and then apparently that scene went on
much longer like it was a very graphic
sex italians are involved that's what i
said
they showed that to like test audiences
and they're like absolutely not they
probably had absolutely nothing they
probably have an extended italian edit
out there somewhere i've never heard of
it i've never heard that it yeah it
might have gotten released i'm sure
that
you shot that [ __ ]
check that out yes indeed
yeah we're saving that well it was just
really weird because
i mean they seemed like close but then
like when he started like all macking on
her and stuff and she was just kind of
like at first she was like oh no well
all right and then she would she even
said like later that she wasn't
like she didn't feel bad about it
right
because then doesn't she go well she
goes to like confession or whatever and
she tells the priest like
he just does it to hurt god yeah like he
i don't know but but she seemed like
okay with it i think even during his
birthday party that scene where they
have his birthday party and he goes up
in the thing like she even goes up into
the room like hey are we gonna like do
it
and i was just kind of like
weird it's very weird but then like he
ends up like shooting her and then
anyway so you know
but she doesn't help him in the movie
you're right like he just kills them so
they so they didn't go with that angle
but they were they were humping but they
didn't
yeah like she didn't have anything she
didn't know he was gonna do zack's in
there talking about old school logic
that kids had back in the you know
[ __ ] i could quote what he said
that's just [ __ ] funny but yeah that
old school logic was was [ __ ] a trip
[ __ ]
they also believed
zach i just heard it fourth grader logic
yeah yeah
you get a girl pregnant by peeing in her
butt
like that i had heard that before yeah
they would just [ __ ] say okay
weird [ __ ] i mean close
sort of like
you know the you know the hook story
about the [ __ ] guy whether the people
were making out in there
and the hooks hanging from it they
thought that was a real story they would
get
legend and reality was from serial
killers mixed up um
yeah because well this is about an
internet so there's no way to change so
it's just old school ways of thinking
and talking and
rumor would get mixed in with fact and
you would get a real contaminated
version of something that really did
happen and the imagination would run a
while back in the 70s and 80s it was
kind of a good time good time to be
young of course adults
i think could could navigate their way
through the [ __ ]
well i don't know because a lot of it
does not adults believe [ __ ] a lot
of them like believed all of that like
poisoned halloween candy and all that
kind of crap in half which that happened
well it happened one time but it was uh
the it was the kid's dad yeah he
poisoned his own kids he poisoned his
own kids yeah and one of the neighbor
kids although the neighborhood didn't
eat the thing but he was trying to get
life insurance money right but that's
like literally the only
as far as i know that's the only uh time
that that's ever happened yeah i'll i'll
eventually remember some [ __ ] that they
believed that they thought really
happened back in the december well the
thing about it and i think we might have
talked about because i think we've done
a show about urban legends but um
because i read a lot of urban legends
and if you read like a lot of
folklorists and stuff like that they try
to trace back like where it came from it
came from now some urban legends do have
some basis in something that really
happened but a lot of times like as it
gets repeated like people just keep
adding like crazier and crazier details
but there is like a germ of reality in
there yeah um i remember it's one of
them now man uh-oh this was [ __ ] r
rated
that they uh that rod stewart passed out
and they sent him to the hospital and
pumped his stomach and he had a gallon
of [ __ ] semen in it yeah i've heard
that one never doubt i've heard that one
yeah and people thought that was real
not quite it's a gerbil one knock yeah i
was going to say not quite as famous as
richard gere in the gerbil terrible in
his butt but yeah
all made up none of that
although some 70s i'm gonna say i mean
if you get your rocks off by having a
gerbil inserted in your butt i mean i
probably don't i'd probably deny that to
you it would kill the german maybe
that's part of the appeal animal cruelty
i know it is
i'm not saying that richard care really
yeah
i'm just saying that if you were really
doing that then you would like be
denying it
that's all it came up with some crazy
[ __ ] in the 70s well see that see that
kind of urban legend always kind of like
fascinates me because i don't think
that's like based on reality but i'm
like where did that idea come from like
who thought
of like hey i'm gonna put part of a
habitrail like up my ass and then like
like who came up with that
friedrich nietzsche talked about that he
said if you're gonna lie you have to
make a [ __ ]
the more absurd the claim is the more
likely the people will believe it so if
you're going to lie lie big
because maybe some people be like oh
well because why would they make up why
would they make that up that's what they
yeah another another
big thing of advice that was later on
was lie big and lie often
all right and [ __ ]
you'll eventually [ __ ] people will
believe you
danny rowling says i'm surprised to talk
about the movie uh red flags weren't
going off in the priest mind when sonny
was standing in the doorway and the door
slammed shut by itself yeah i was just
kind of like maybe he's like a priest
and he's like oh i see like demonic like
ghosty [ __ ] all the time but he's like
yeah he's clearly looking at the hall
and sonny's like standing there not
touching the door like several feet away
from the door and the door slams and
he's just kind of like huh
well
he doesn't even like finish blessing the
[ __ ] now if look at phoenix he's going
rod stewart that's totally true tom that
was not true
[Laughter]
zach says it's weird richard gere was
like the hottie of the 70s and 80s but
i've never been super into him he's kind
of too pretty
yeah i mean
i always thought he was just like okay
looking i mean he didn't seem like
nothing special i don't and i don't know
why the gerbil
sometimes this gerbil or hamster i guess
they're kind of like the same thing but
it's i don't know why that specifically
got attached to him i've heard it about
other celebrities but 99 of the time
it's richard gere
and i don't know why that is i don't
know why that is
um oracle just showed up
and that is slipping
yeah
it's all right as soon as we post it
it'll go right up you can watch it yeah
but yeah so i don't know should we watch
andyville 3d tonight or should we just
get some
you want to do some watch something else
well you should talk about them probably
well no but that's that's later well
yeah that's the one that's all right
that's not the one the lamp is it no
that's the first one fourth one okay
yeah i don't think i've seen 3d
i have but it's been a long time
um
but we'll see because i was kind of
curious because i saw the hbo had them
both all right so i was just kind of
like okay
i mean you know that's because i'm kind
of tired from less so i don't want
anything to watch anything that's too
long or involved
i just want to watch something that's
like kind of kind of goofy or fun or
whatever but yeah so uh yeah we're doing
uh them is gonna be the
movie review for the recorded one yeah
that we're putting up later this week
because i knew you'd be excited about
that because you're like that's a good
movie you like the big ants movie and i
haven't seen it in life since i was a
kid i had a lot of good army action and
the army was really in it
from if i remember correctly
and on the
on the main show on wednesday night
we're going to be talking about
lewis carroll and his relationship with
alice liddell
the girl that yeah alice in wonderland i
don't know if it was zoology i mean i
don't want to go that far because it's
like
i think it'll be an interesting
discussion because
there's kind of like a difference
between the way people saw childhood in
the victorian era and the way people see
childhood now i didn't have the
childhood in the victoria so i don't
really know
i don't know like where i come down
honestly yeah you know there was people
that used to call basically little kids
homeless little kids they used to call
them street meats and things like that
there's all you know weird
they were weird they're predating on
them street meats
that's [ __ ] up yeah you fed them that
you could do what you wanted with them
yikes those little starving children in
those
cities not even starving just real poor
you know i mean hungry
but uh anyway the uh
was gonna say yeah people don't know
that uh in some of those real high
budget movies of the 50s that really was
the army well yeah they always had i
mean they well they for sure gave them
like uh permission to use like a lot of
the equipment and all that kind of stuff
because well it was kind of like part of
the helping out hollywood and the army
got merged in world war ii yeah they
started working with them in world war
ii
why
why use extras when you have a real army
in training right there and just give
them some more training and run them
around in front of the camera the
russians and the germans did the same
thing
and then in the 50s they were in the
cold war they were still doing the same
thing you know they'll activate an army
unit and if the activation and the
mobilization is part of the training
you know then they go to a
shoot the movie they evidently shoot
live rounds sometimes it'd be like live
fire training and they get it all on
tape and it was good promotion for the
us army
you know it makes a lot of sense it's
propaganda for the army and if i
remember correctly i haven't seen this
move i haven't seen them in a long time
when the army guys are shooting up those
[ __ ] giant ants and there really are
practical effect ants if i remember
correctly i remember thinking at the
time that that looked like real 45 acp
rounds going through that thing
you know it wasn't square bro squib
explosions like you would today it was
live rounds
well i guess we'll find out we'll find
out i got to see it again i remember
seeing either if it looks like a live
round they were shooting with thompson
submachine guns at about 10 meters and
blowing [ __ ] off the damn ant and there
was an ant puppet but they were big you
know nine feet long probably
four or five feet high
look good from what i remember i said
been a lot of times i've seen it i mean
if we have time we'll watch it tonight
but we have to watch like something for
the matinee and then that we need to
watch it either tonight or tomorrow
night so we can like record the review
and get it up by the end of the week so
that's what's coming up for the rest of
the week so yeah we'll probably watch
emilyville 3d tonight because might as
well since they're both up on there so
uh if you're going to see the fireworks
or whatever uh be safe don't get eaten
by mosquitoes or blow your fingers off
or anything like that uh so have a good
holiday and we will see you guys again
tomorrow evening bye